it's a tough time for the Afghan
security forces Taliban attacks have
increased their suffering heavy
casualties and the prospect of a
withdrawal of US forces hangs over them
yet young men are still joining up some
for patriotic reasons for others it's
the only way to get a job despite the
risks the Afghan government says it
doesn't keep a record of casualties but
President Ashraf Ghani announced earlier
this year that 45,000 police and army
personnel have been killed fighting the
Taliban since 2015 mid-waist Karimi was
an army bomb disposal engineer in
Helmand province he knew the risks he
was blinded in both eyes and lost a leg
when a roadside device exploded as he
tried to defuse it I was aware of the
danger I've seen friends wounded while
working on mines losing an arm or a leg
I wasn't scared to lose an arm or a leg
is the sacrifice we have to make to
serve this country and more have made
that sacrifice since the u.s. pulled out
the bulk of its forces in Afghanistan
that once numbered a hundred thousand
the 13,000 Americans left don't fight on
the front lines that's left to the
Afghan security forces and they say they
don't miss the u.s. manpower as much as
its military technology and that means
money we have a very sophisticated army
and a defense and security forces all we
need right now is financial support
because the Afghan national offensive
security forces has essentially been
fighting this war since 2014 and no
major foreign force forces have been
engaging in a battle in a big scale or
even at a smaller scale the support we
get from the resolute support and also
from the US forces here is only limited
to financial even though peace talks
between the Taliban and the u.s. have
collapsed many people still hope the
negotiations will resume in the near
future but the acknowledged peace in
Afghanistan is not going to be
straightforward the consensus is that
the Afghan security forces can't face
the Taliban without outside help that's
a given but there is another potential
problem in the future when peace finally
comes to Afghanistan
how can two bitter enemies who fought in
kill for 18 years come together in a
National Defense Force it's one of the
many problems Afghanistan will need to
overcome if peace is to become a reality
instead of a dream Tony Berkeley al
Jazeera Kabul